Hi there, Shankar here. Today's episode is the last one in our series called You 2.0. If you haven't heard the other episodes, please take a listen. This one comes from our archives. It's about a tool that humans have used for hundreds of years to avoid a common mistake. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthu. All of us have days when despite our best efforts, everything just goes wrong. Sometimes terribly wrong. It was a devastating problem.
大家好，我是尚卡尔。今天的节目是我们名为“你 2.0”系列的最后一集。如果你还没听过之前的节目，请务必去听一听。这一期来自我们的档案库。它讲述了一个人类使用数百年来避免常见错误的工具。这里是隐秘大脑，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都有过这样的日子：尽管我们尽了最大努力，一切还是出了岔子。有时甚至是糟糕透顶。这是一个极其严重的问题。
Atul Gawande is a surgeon at Brighamon Women's Hospital in Boston. He's also a writer. You might have read his work in the New Yorker or in Slate. A few years ago, Atul was at work, operating on a patient he refers to as Mr. Hageman. I was taking out a tumor of the adrenal gland laparoscopically. He'd performed this procedure dozens of times before, but this time was particularly tricky. Mr. Hageman's tumor was behind his liver, nestled tightly against an important blood vessel. The main blood vessel returning the blood of the body to the heart.
阿图尔·葛文德是波士顿布莱根妇女医院的外科医生。他也是一名作家。你可能在《纽约客》或《Slate》杂志上读过他的作品。几年前，阿图尔在工作时，为一个他称之为Hageman先生的病人做手术。我当时在用腹腔镜切除一个肾上腺肿瘤。他以前做过几十次这个手术，但这次特别棘手。Hageman先生的肿瘤长在肝脏后面，紧紧贴着一条重要的血管。那条把全身血液送回心脏的主血管。
It's known as the Vena Kava. Atul began the surgery and everything was going smoothly. He was almost done detaching the tumor when all of a sudden he nicked the blood vessel. I ended up creating a hole in the Vena Kava, which meant that he then pretty quickly lost his entire blood volume into his abdomen, a complete blackout on the screen and utter chaos. Atul took the man's heart in his hand
它被称为下腔静脉。阿图尔开始手术，一切都很顺利。他差点就剥离完肿瘤了，突然之间，他割破了那条血管。我最终在下腔静脉上弄破了一个洞，这意味着他很快就把全身的血液都流进腹腔里了，屏幕上一片漆黑，场面一片混乱。阿图尔用手抓住了这个男人的心脏
and began compressing it to keep blood flowing to his brain. I mean, he lost basically 10 times his body volume in blood, but we were able to give him enough blood to keep his circulation going. He had a cardiac arrest twice. We were finally able to repair the hole in the Vena Cave and get the tumor out and have him recover. A happy ending and a first blush, a textbook case of medical heroics. A doctor makes a mistake, but he fixes it, taking a heart into his bare hands and squeezing
开始按压它，以保持血液流向他的大脑。我的意思是，他基本上流失了相当于十倍体重的血量，但我们能够给他输送足够的血液来维持他的循环。他心脏骤停了两次。我们终于能够修补下腔静脉上的洞，切除肿瘤，并让他康复了。这是一个大团圆结局，乍一看，这是一个医学英雄主义的教科书式案例。医生犯了错，但他修复了错误，他赤手空拳抓起一颗心脏并进行挤压
life back into his patient's body. This is the stuff of countless movies and TV shows. Our whole idea of the hero is the person who can kind of know it all, save the day on their own just by force of their brain and their skill. But skill and brain power were not the reason Mr. Hagueman survived. Atol says what actually saved his patient's life was a plan the surgical team had made before they began the surgery.
将生命重新注入病人的体内。这是无数电影和电视剧的素材。我们对英雄的全部概念，就是一个能够无所不知、仅凭自己的大脑和技能就能独自拯救世界的人。但技能和智力并不是Hageman先生幸存的原因。阿图尔说，真正救了他病人性命的，是外科团队在开始手术前制定的一项计划。
The plan wasn't grand or complicated. In fact, it was a humble checklist. And what happened was, when we ran the checklist, when we got to the part where we said, you know, what's the goal of the operation and tell me anything unexpected about this. And I mentioned to the anesthesiologist that this tumor was pretty tightly against the Vena Kava. The anesthesiologist then made a plan to get more blood into the room, just in case.
这个计划并不宏大，也不复杂。事实上，它是一份不起眼的核对清单。事情是这样的，当我们过了一遍核对清单，当我们到了讨论手术目标、并告诉我关于这次手术任何意想不到的事情的环节时。我向麻醉师提到这个肿瘤紧紧贴着下腔静脉。麻醉师随后制定了一个计划，准备了更多的血进手术室，以防万一。
Just in case. When disaster came, he was prepared, and that was the only reason that this man got through it. Today on Hidden Brain, the subtle biases that cause very smart and very skilled people to become their own worst enemies, and how innovators have found a way to help pilots, doctors, frankly any of us perform at our best. It's a story of an ancient insight applied to modern life, and even though you might not know it, this innovation shapes life and death decisions that affect all of us.
以防万一。当灾难降临时，他做好了准备，而这正是这个人能够挺过难关的唯一原因。今天在隐秘大脑中，我们将探讨导致极其聪明和技能高超的人成为自己最大敌人的微妙偏见，以及创新者如何找到方法帮助飞行员、医生——坦率地说，帮助我们所有人发挥出最佳水平。这是一个将古老的洞察力应用于现代生活的故事，尽管你可能不知道，但这种创新正在塑造影响我们所有人生死攸关的决策。
We began in the depths of the Great Depression. It was a time of great suffering and people were looking for inspiration. Many found it in the heroes who were inventing the modern age of flight. One effort in particular caught the public's attention. Boeing was developing an airplane that was said to be different from anything that came before it. In the press, the Model 299 was known as the Flying Fortress. It's 15 tons and is reported to have cost nearly half a million. Something like the Boeing 299 was a huge story.
我们从大萧条的深渊开始说起。那是一个充满苦难的时代，人们在寻找灵感。许多人在那些开创现代飞行时代英雄身上找到了灵感。其中一项努力特别引起了公众的注意。波音公司正在开发一款据说与以往任何飞机都不同的飞机。在媒体上，299型被称为“飞行堡垒”。它重达 15 吨，据报道造价近五十万美元。像波音 299 这样轰动的事物是一条大新闻。
Roger Conner is a curator at the Smithsonian National Air and Space Museum in Washington, DC. We're standing in a part of the museum dedicated to the golden age of flight, gazing up at a model of Boeing's flying fortress. And is that the silver plane that we're looking at up high? Right, so a very streamlined four-engine aircraft, and this was really a marvel of its day. In other words, the Model 299 was a big deal, both for Boeing and for the United States. It was a success story in America that was really challenged by depression. It was also a very big deal for the U.S. military.
罗杰·康纳是华盛顿特区史密森尼国家航空航天博物馆的策展人。我们站在博物馆专属航空黄金时代的展区，抬头凝视着波音“飞行堡垒”的模型。我们高处看到的那个是银色的飞机吗？对，这是一架非常流线型的四引擎飞机，这在当时确实是一个奇迹。换句话说，299型是一个大事件，对波音公司和美国来说都是如此。这是美国在深受大萧条打击的背景下的一个成功故事。对美军来说，这也是一件大事。
By all accounts, it's a wonder of technology. So the Air Corps pilots that see it are in awe, it's a fantastic machine. The plane arrived on the scene at a time when the nation was obsessed with the possibilities of flight. Air racing was not just a niche activity for wealthy hobbyists, it was kind of a national craze and obsession. The fastest things on wings struck their amazing stuff. You know, kids would obsess over who was leading the rankings at the Cleveland Air Races.
无论从哪个角度看，它都是工程学的奇迹。因此，看到它的空军飞行员都惊叹不已，这是一台极其出色的机器。这架飞机问世时，全国正痴迷于飞行的可能性。航空赛不仅仅是富裕爱好者的一个小众活动，它在某种程度上是一种全国性的狂热和痴迷。长着翅膀的最快飞行器展示了它们惊人的性能。你知道的，孩子们会痴迷于谁在克利夫兰飞行赛的排名中领先。
The military was obsessed, too, with the idea of long-range bombers, planes that could better protect the US coastline and give the nation an edge if another great war erupted. In 1934, the Army Air Corps put out a proposal to the nation's aviation companies and challenged them to build a new long-range bomber for the military. The prototypes were to go up against each other at a flight competition the following year. The two leading competitors are Douglas and Boeing. Douglas was really starting to dominate the American aircraft industry at this moment.
军方同样痴迷于远程轰炸机概念，这种飞机可以更好地保护美国海岸线，并在爆发另一场大战时赋予国家优势。1934年，陆军航空兵向全国的航空企业发布了一份提案，挑战他们为军方建造一款新的远程轰炸机。原型机将在第二年的飞行比赛中一决高下。两家领先的竞争对手是道格拉斯和波音。道格拉斯当时正开始主导美国的飞机制造业。
Their DC-2 was becoming the hot passenger airliner and was quickly putting Boeing into the background in that industry. So once the Air Corps announces this new bomber competition, Boeing is really eager to show off and demonstrate that they can lead the pack. Boeing had a lot to prove. By the time the competition rolled around, it had an ace up its sleeve, the flying fortress. On October 30th, 1935, the day of the competition rolled around, it had an ace-up at sleeve, the flying fortress.
他们的 DC-2 正在成为热门的客运客机，并迅速使波音在该行业中退居幕后。因此，一旦空军宣布这项新的轰炸机竞赛，波音公司就迫不及待地想要炫耀并证明他们能够引领群雄。波音有很多需要证明的地方。到比赛到来时，它手中握有一张王牌——飞行堡垒。1935年10月30日，也就是比赛的那天，它手中握有一张王牌——飞行堡垒。
On October 30th, 1935, the day of the competition, Boeing's streamlined silver behemoth was the clear frontrunner. The morning of the competition, flight teams from Boeing, Douglas and Martin assembled with military leaders at Wrightfield in Dayton, Ohio. Early in the morning, with 9 o'clock in the morning, and apparently by all accounts, a very beautiful day. So kind of ideal conditions for a late October day in Ohio. And perfect day for a test flight, really. A crowd watched as the Boeing 299 taxi to the runway. Advances, the power, engine spool up, rolling down the runway. It advances the power, engine spool up, is rolling down the runway. The beautiful airplane lifted into the air. It had all the makings of a winner.
1935年10月30日，比赛当天，波音公司流线型的银色庞然大物显然是领头羊。比赛当天早上，来自波音、道格拉斯和马丁公司的飞行团队与军事领导人在俄亥俄州代顿的赖特菲尔德集合。清晨，早上9点，据各方描述，这是一个非常美好的日子。对于俄亥俄州10月下旬的一天来说，这是一种理想的条件。对于试飞来说，这真的是完美的一天。人群看着波音 299 滑向跑道。推力加大，发动机加速运转，在跑道上滑行。推力加大，发动机加速运转，在跑道上滑行。这架美丽的飞机升空了。它具备了一切获胜的要素。
And then the observers noted that the aircraft starts to abruptly pitch up. So as it takes off, rather than gradually rising and building up speed, the nose just starts to pick up and up. And immediately observers on the ground realized something's wrong. Very wrong. At 300 feet, the aircraft stall. As people watched in horror, the flying fortress began to plummet toward the earth. It impacts the ground in a flat attitude and in person to flames. There were five crewmen on board. ground in a flat attitude and in person to flames.
然后，观察员注意到飞机开始突然昂首。因此，在起飞时，机头并没有逐渐上升和积蓄速度，而是开始不断向上抬起。地面上的观察员立刻意识到出事了。大错特错了。在 300 英尺的高度，飞机失速了。在人们惊恐的注视下，飞行堡垒开始向地面坠落。它以平直的姿态撞击地面并陷入火海。机上有五名机组人员。地平线呈水平姿态，陷入烈火之中。
There were five crewmen on board. Major ployer Hill, who was the chief of flight test for Wright Field, Leslie Tower, who was the chief flight test pilot. There was also a Donald Tut who was acting as the co-pilot. There was a mechanic on board, Mark Kugler, and John Cutting, who was one of the aeronautical engineers involved with the program. Obsovers on the ground raised to what the wreck.
机上有五名机组人员。赖特菲尔德飞行测试负责人少校普洛耶·希尔，首席试飞员莱斯利·托尔。还有担任副驾驶的唐纳德·塔特。机上有一名机械师马克·库格勒，以及参与该项目的航空工程师之一约翰·卡丁。地面的观察员冲向残骸。
Obviously an aircraft like this has a lot of fuel on board. And so when in this case, because the aircraft came down relatively flat, it only just started to spin in. It would have been fairly apparent to the people on the ground there was a good chance of survivors. So it's kind of a worst case scenario where you see that the aircraft is involved in terms of being on fire, but you know there's people on there that are likely still alive. So it's going to be a great hazard to both the rescuers as well as the occupants of the aircraft. Three of those occupants survived, but two died,
显然，像这样的飞机机载燃油非常多。因此，在这种情况下，由于飞机相对平着着地，它只是开始旋转坠毁。对于地面上的人来说，生还的几率很大，这是显而易见的。所以这有点像最糟糕的情况，你看到飞机卷入了火灾，但你知道上面可能还有人活着。因此，这对救援人员和机上人员来说都是巨大的危险。机上的三名乘员幸存下来，但有两人丧生，
blow your hill and lessly tower. Both were highly experienced pilots. Almost immediately people asked, what made the flying fortress crash? This aircraft did have an autopilot, and not unlike a lot of accidents today, attention centered on that. So was the autopilot somehow engaged
普洛耶·希尔和莱斯利·托尔。两人都是经验丰富的飞行员。几乎立刻，人们就问，是什么导致了飞行堡垒坠毁？这架飞机确实有自动驾驶仪，和现在的许多事故一样，注意力集中在那上面。那么，是不是自动驾驶仪不知何故接合了
where it was overriding the inputs of the crew members. So that was one focus of the investigation, but very quickly attention turned to a control locking mechanism, which was that was one of the advanced features of this aircraft was that it had its own built-in mechanism for locking the elevator for when it was essentially parked on the ground. The elevator determines the pitch of the plane, basically the movement of the nose up or down. For most planes at the time, elevator locks were on the outside, meaning ground crew had
它覆盖了机组人员的输入操作。所以这是调查的焦点之一，但很快注意力转向了一个控制锁定机制，这是这架飞机的高级功能之一，它有自己的内置机制，用于在飞机基本上停在地面上时锁定升降舵。升降舵决定了飞机的俯仰，也就是机头上下的运动。对于当时的绝大多数飞机来说，升降舵锁都在外部，这意味着地勤人员必须
to unlock them before takeoff. But in the Model 299, the elevator lock was inside the cabin of the plane. The crew had forgotten to unlock it. And so after the plane took off, the pilots found they couldn't level off. The nose just kept climbing. Unfortunately, in the, you know, just the matter of the few seconds that they're airborne, it's just not enough time to deal with it. So less than 20 seconds between the time the wheels leave the ground and the aircraft is entering the stalls.
在起飞前解锁它们。但在 299 型飞机上，升降舵锁位于飞机的机舱内部。机组人员忘记解锁它了。因此，飞机起飞后，飞行员发现他们无法保持水平飞行。机头一直在往上爬。不幸的是，在他们身处空中的这短短几秒钟内，根本没有时间去处理它。因此，从车轮离开地面到飞机进入失速状态，前后不到 20 秒。
It's just not enough time for that awareness to dawn be able to reach the controls, particularly as the aircraft is beginning to stall, then the ability of somebody to find the controls and solve the problem. It's too late and they may not be able to physically do it because they're getting thrown around the aircraft. The death of the two men was a crushing blow. For military leaders and the aviation industry, the crash prompted an unsettling question. If experienced pilots like Ployer Hill and Leslie Tower could make fatal mistakes with the flying fortress, what did that mean for the future of manned air flight? What planes simply becoming too complicated to fly?
根本没有足够的时间让这种意识觉醒并能够够到操纵杆，特别是当飞机开始失速时，某人找到操纵杆并解决问题的能力。已经太晚了，他们可能无法在物理上做到这一点，因为他们在飞机里被甩来甩去。这两名男子的死是一个沉重的打击。对于军事领导人和航空业来说，这次坠机引发了一个令人不安的问题。如果像普洛耶·希尔和莱斯利·托尔这样经验丰富的飞行员都会在飞行堡垒上犯下致命错误，那对载人航空的未来意味着什么？飞机是不是变得太复杂而无法飞行了？
At this moment in the mid-1930s, the performance of aircraft are changing so rapidly, there's so many new complex systems coming into play, rather delicate systems in some ways. So everything from retractable landing gear to turbochargers for engines, all of which require their own detailed specifications for operation. And so now a pilot was beginning to become overwhelmed with the degree of complexity with
在20世纪30年代中期这一时期，飞机的性能变化如此之快，有这么多新的复杂系统投入使用，在某些方面甚至是相当脆弱的系统。因此，从可收放起落架到发动机涡轮增压器，所有这些都需要自己详细的操作规范。因此，现在飞行员开始被各种系统的复杂程度压得喘不过气来
all these systems and how they interfaced with one another. It became difficult to keep them straight. To many of us, the instinctive solution to this problem might be more training. Spend more time in the plane. Get to know it like you know your own home. Understand its quirks inside and out. But Roger says that kind of thinking may not have saved the men who died in the crash. The pilots actually had lots of experience with the plane.
所有这些系统以及它们是如何相互对接的。要把它们理清楚变得很困难。对我们许多人来说，解决这个问题的本能方案可能是更多的培训。花更多的时间在飞机上。像了解自己的家一样了解它。从里到外了解它的脾气。但罗杰说，那种想法可能并没有拯救在坠机中丧生的那些人。飞行员实际上有很多驾驶该飞机的经验。
They had been flying it for several months. Things had become rather routine in testing this aircraft. So certainly the crew, both at right field and with Boeing were fairly familiar with it, they had clearly become quite comfortable with the operation of the aircraft and were used to its quirks and how it performed. So if more training was in the answer, what was?
他们已经驾驶几个月了。测试这架飞机的过程变得相当例行公事。因此，可以肯定的是，无论是赖特菲尔德的机组人员还是波音公司的机组人员，对它都相当熟悉，他们显然对这架飞机的操作变得非常舒适，并且习惯了它的脾气和性能。所以，如果更多的培训不是答案，那什么才是？
The solution that military leaders devised was fundamentally about human psychology. Pilots were not screwing up because they were incompetent. They were screwing up because they were very good. So good that they were completely sure they knew what they were doing. They didn't feel the need to slow down, go over the basics, like unlocking the elevator before taking off. The military responded with a new idea that was actually an old idea. The checklist.
军事领导人设计出的解决方案从根本上讲是关于人类心理学的。飞行员搞砸不是因为他们无能。他们搞砸是因为他们太优秀了。优秀到他们完全确信自己知道自己在做什么。他们不觉得有必要慢下来，重温基础知识，比如起飞前解锁升降舵。军方以一个新想法作出了回应，这个想法实际上是一个旧想法。核对清单。
This is from a 1943 military training film. After you get the plane off the ramp and down near the runway, you're ready for the run-up. One of the most important checks of all. Setter at an angle. That gets all your props safe over concrete for the run-up. And if there's a guy behind you, you won't blast him when you rev him up. What's fascinating is you look at the effort that went into training these guys. The training videos that came out of that time are really magnificent. They're frankly, you'd be hard pressed to find something as well produced today for the same purpose.
这段视频出自 1943 年的一部军事训练片。当你把飞机开下坡道到达跑道附近时，你就准备好进行试车了。这是所有检查中最重要的一项之一。将飞机倾斜一个角度。这能让你的所有螺旋桨安全地越过混凝土进行试车。如果你身后有人，当你轰油门时就不会喷到他。最迷人的是，看看花在培训这些家伙身上的精力。那个时期出品的训练视频真的很精彩。坦率地说，你很难找到今天能出于同样目的制作出如此精良的东西。
Checklists like these were widely implemented in the military in the years after the Boeing 299 crash. They cover tasks that to a train pilot might seem mind-numbingly obvious. Make sure your crew is in the right position and that the hatches are closed. Turn off the automatic pilot. Make sure your flight controls and tail wheel are unlocked. Check that your brakes have air pressure, that your warning lights work. Supercharger that's set correctly to low-blower, your altimeter set to the correct field elevation. Mixture controls, you have to be in your full-rich position, carburetor air, you want it in the cold position for maximum performance. So, to be honest, as somebody who doesn't know how to fly an aircraft, a lot of this is gobbledigook to me.
像这样的核对清单在波音 299 坠毁后的几年里在军队中得到了广泛推行。它们涵盖了一些对训练有素的飞行员来说可能显得极其显而易见的任务。确保你的机组人员处于正确的位置并且舱门已关闭。关闭自动驾驶仪。确保你的飞行操纵面和尾轮未锁定。检查你的刹车是否有气压，警告灯是否工作。增压器是否正确设置为低增压器，高度表是否设置为正确的机场海拔高度。混合比控制，你必须处于全富油位置，化油器空气，为了获得最大性能，你希望它处于冷空气位置。老实说，作为一个不会开飞机的人，这里面很多都是天书。
But I'm imagining that for most people who are pilots, this stuff is actually completely routine. That this is no different than me getting into my car in the morning and saying, open the door, sit down and close the door behind you. That it seems really basic stuff. And I would imagine that someone would have told me to do that when I got into my car each morning. I would say, what kind of bureaucratic nonsense is this?
但我猜想，对于大多数飞行员来说，这些东西其实完全是例行公事。这跟我早上上车说，开门，坐下，随手关上车门没什么两样。这看起来真的很基础。而且我想象如果有人在我每天早上上车时告诉我这么做。我会说，这是什么官僚主义的废话？
I know how to fly a plane. I'm an experienced pilot. Stop telling me how to do my job. Certainly. So this has been a huge problem in aviation culture and it's one that does crop up. In other words, checklists can help experts slow down, but only if the experts bother to listen. It turns out lots of pilots didn't
我会开飞机。我是个经验丰富的飞行员。别告诉我要怎么做我的工作。当然。所以这一直是航空文化中的一个大问题，而且确实经常出现。换句话说，核对清单可以帮助专家慢下来，但前提是专家们愿意听。事实证明，很多飞行员并没有
want to listen. How to make them? Harness another large bias in the brain, our willingness to be swept up by stories. There are so many accounts now of episodes where people have winged the checklist or not paid attention and something bad's happened. So, particularly in commercial aviation and over the last half century, there's been a very strong cultural emphasis on really the storytelling that you go and look at these accidents. So, Air Florida 1982 here in Washington, D. Washington DC is a very famous one There's the crash over the Everglades
想要倾听。如何让它们听从？利用大脑中的另一个重大偏见，即我们乐于被故事所吸引的倾向。现在有这么多的事故记录，讲的是人们草率应付核对清单或不够专心而导致了不好的事情发生。因此，特别是在商业航空领域和过去的半个世纪里，人们对讲故事有一种非常强烈的文化重视，即你去观察这些事故。比如华盛顿的 1982 年佛罗里达航空，华盛顿特区是一个非常著名的例子，还有大沼泽地坠机事件
Where they were focused on the nose gear there's a whole series of a very well-known Accidents that are brought up in training at various points that are discussing simulator exercises and are on the present, really, in the literature. So there are inevitably a number of points where a commercial airline pilot will have witnessed these cockpit recreations and seen the voice
他们专注于前起落架，有一系列众所周知的事故在培训的各个阶段被提出来讨论模拟器练习，并且在文献中确实无处不在。因此，商业航空公司的飞行员不可避免地会在多个场合目睹这些驾驶舱重现，并看到各种机组人员草率行事的语音
transcripts of various episodes where crews have kind of winged it. They've flown by the seat of the pants, they've not followed procedures, not used the checklist in the right way, and something bad has come about of it. The commercial aviation industry developed a culture of making and using checklists through training, simulations, and storytelling. The commercial aviation industry developed a culture of making and using checklists through training, simulations, and storytelling. The military went a step further and Harnas brought a theme, patriotism, freedom. America goes to war.
文字记录。他们凭直觉飞行，没有遵循程序，没有以正确的方式使用核对清单，结果导致了不好的事情发生。商业航空业通过培训、模拟和讲故事，形成了一种制作和使用核对清单的文化。商业航空业通过培训、模拟和讲故事，形成了一种制作和使用核对清单的文化。军队则更进一步，利用了一个主题：爱国主义、自由。美国参战了。
Men of the army, Navy and Marines, reinforce the battlefronts on six continents to save the homes and ideals of free men from access domination. Despite the crash in Dayton, the army ended up ordering thousands of Boeing's Model 299, which it renamed the B-17. Once the nation entered World War II, thousands of young would-be pilots put up their hands to fly those planes. Each of the young cadets is to get real flying instruction under the army's new plan of hands to fly as an observer
陆军、海军和海军陆战队的士兵们，在六个大洲增援前线，以拯救自由人的家园和理想免受轴心国的统治。尽管代顿发生了坠机事故，但陆军最终还是订购了数千架波音 299 型飞机，并将其重新命名为 B-17。一旦国家参加第二次世界大战，成千上万年轻的准飞行员就举手要求驾驶这些飞机。根据陆军的新计划，每一位年轻学员都将接受真正的飞行指导，作为观察员飞行
if not as a pilot. Many of these new pilots were not officers, though. Many were young and listed men. Most of whom were, you know, 19, 20-year-olds, literally fresh off the farm, you know, with not a great deal of training. And so they're going to be operating very complex systems. In a lot of cases, the aircraft are even getting more complicated than they're going to 9.9. For these new pilots, checklists served as a safety net.
如果不是作为飞行员的话。然而，许多这些新飞行员并不是军官。许多是年轻的士兵。其中大多数人，你知道的，是 19、20 岁的年轻人，简直刚从农场出来，你知道的，没有接受过太多的训练。因此，他们将操作非常复杂的系统。在许多情况下，飞机的复杂程度甚至比他们之前接触的还要高。对于这些新飞行员来说，核对清单就像是一个安全网。
They helped them get these massive planes off the ground. They were used by flight teams to troubleshoot problems in the air, and perhaps most importantly, they helped exhausted pilots avoid mistakes while returning home from a mission. We can't know for sure how the use of checklists affected America's success in the war, but Roger is sure that they saved lives. If those checklists had not been integrated to that level at the start of World War II, it's reasonable to assume that many hundreds and probably thousands of lives would have been lost due to that.
它们帮助这些庞大的飞机离开地面。它们被飞行团队用于在空中排查问题，或许最重要的是，它们帮助筋疲力尽的飞行员在完成任务返航时避免犯错。我们无法确定核对清单对美国在战争中的成功有多大影响，但罗杰确信它们挽救了生命。如果在二战开始时没有将这些核对清单整合到那个水平，可以合理地推测，由于这一点，成百上千甚至数千人的生命将会丧失。
Today, checklists are essential to the aviation world. In fact, there are big reasons commercial aviation is significantly safer than driving your car on a highway. Checklists have become ubiquitous and lots of other fields too, feels where the work is complex and the cost of mistakes is high. Construction crews now rely on checklists to build high-rise office towers. NASA has detailed to-do lists for astronauts. And then there's a world of medicine.
如今，核对清单对航空世界至关重要。事实上，这就是商业航空明显比在高速公路上开车安全得多的重要原因。核对清单在许多其他领域也无处不在，这些领域工作复杂，犯错的代价很高。建筑施工人员现在依靠核对清单来建造高层办公楼。美国宇航局为宇航员制定了详细的待办事项清单。然后是医学界。
I don't get through a week of surgery without us catching something that would have meant the patient didn't get as good care as they would have otherwise. Coming up, how the powerful culture of aviation check checklist has inspired and antagonized the field of medicine and how one grieving mother's question helped to change an entire culture. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Atul Gawande is a surgeon at Brigham & Women's Hospital in Boston and the author of the Checklist Manifesto.
我一周的外科手术中，总能抓到一些本来会导致患者得不到应有良好治疗的问题。接下来，强大的航空核对清单文化如何启发并激怒了医学界，以及一个悲伤母亲的问题如何帮助改变了整个文化。请继续收听。这里是隐秘大脑，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。阿图尔·葛文德是波士顿布莱根妇女医院的外科医生，也是《核对清单宣言》的作者。
When he began his career in medicine, Checklist weren't something Atul spent a lot of time thinking about. He was drawn to the heroics of doctors, people who, through the force of their intellect and the rigor of that training, could triumph over death and restore patients to productive lives. I went into medicine because I wanted to be able to understand how does the body work, how does it go wrong, and then how can I come in and save the day. What I was really drawn to was in surgery
当他刚开始医学职业生涯时，核对清单并不是阿图尔花很多时间去思考的东西。他被医生的英雄主义所吸引，这些人凭借智力的力量和严格的训练，能够战胜死神，让患者重获生产生活。我进入医学界是因为我想了解身体是如何运作的，它是如何出问题的，然后我该如何介入并拯救世界。我真正被吸引的是外科手术
where it's especially visceral. It's like, how do I save this person with my own hands? Over the years though, adults started to realize that daring and intellect weren't enough, particularly as medicine has become more complicated and doctors have evolved into what he calls super super specialist. I am one of those super super specialists now. I am a
那里尤其直观。就像是，我如何用自己的双手拯救这个人？然而多年来，阿图尔开始意识到，胆识和智力是不够的，特别是随着医学变得越来越复杂，医生已经演变成他所说的超级超级专家。我现在就是那些超级超级专家之一。我是一个
General surgeon in my original training, but then I've narrowed into not only a cancer surgery but a focus on three specific tumors that make me you know feel like I have an area where I can know more than just about anybody at least here regionally, right? So the problem is that even then, I'm not necessarily able to pull together in that moment in time, everything that might matter. Even a super, super specialist can screw up. Having advanced training doesn't guarantee perfection. It's still possible that you'll forget something important, overlook a problem until it's too
我最初接受的是普通外科培训，但我不仅缩小到了癌症外科，还专注于三个特定的肿瘤，这让我觉得我有一个领域，我的了解至少在这里的地区比任何人都多，对吧？所以问题在于，即便如此，我也未必能在那个时间节点上，把所有可能重要的事情都汇集起来。即使是超级超级专家也会搞砸。拥有高级培训并不能保证完美。你仍然可能会忘记重要的事情，忽视一个问题直到为时已晚，或者割破血管，尽管你已经做过几十次同样的手术。
late, or nick a blood vessel, even though you've done the same kind of surgery dozens of times. At old search for a solution led into the aviation world and its culture of checklist. We are famously hold up the airline industry as an example of high reliability performance. You can have planes that are of now immense complexity, immense power, and we have a far lower crash rate than when they were far simpler. And you know, less than one in 200,000 flights have any kind of a mishap and so on. He studied that 1935 crash of the flying fortress.
阿图尔对解决方案的搜寻将他带入了航空世界及其核对清单文化。我们名声远扬地将航空业奉为高可靠性表现的典范。你可以拥有极其复杂、动力巨大的飞机，而我们的坠机率却比它们简单得多的时候要低得多。你知道的，不到二十万分之一的飞行会发生任何事故等等。他研究了 1935 年飞行堡垒的坠机事件。
He couldn't help but compare the military's response to the way his own field response to fatal errors. If we were looking at solving this problem the way we would solve it in medicine, we would say, well, let's have a four-year training fellowship and how to fly the B-17 bomber. And instead, what they did was they created a checklist for the most common ways that even an expert pilot could crash that plane. And that one-page checklist allowed them to fly that plane
他忍不住将军方的反应与他自己的领域对致命错误的反应进行比较。如果我们打算用我们在医学上解决问题的方式来解决这个问题，我们会说，好吧，让我们搞一个为期四年的培训进修班，学习如何驾驶 B-17 轰炸机。而相反，他们做的是为最常见的情况创建了一份核对清单，即使是经验丰富的飞行员也可能因此而让飞机坠毁。那份单页的核对清单让他们得以驾驶那架飞机
two million miles without a single mishap. No four-year specialized training program, get it all into your brain and make it work that way. It was just a whole different way of looking at things, and that's what was powerful to me. Checklists were not, of course, completely absent from the world of medicine. Nurses have long used them in many areas of patient care. But at all says for many doctors, the idea of relying on a checklist was demeaning. Our values as physicians or experts of any kind are that we believe in autonomy. Leave me alone, I've been trained, I know the best thing to do, and that is your best
飞行了两百万英里而没有发生一起事故。没有四年制的专业培训项目，把所有东西塞进你的脑子然后让它那样运作。这只是一种完全不同的看待事物的方式，而这对我来说很有力量。当然，医学界并不是完全没有核对清单。护士在许多患者护理领域长期使用它们。但阿图尔说，对于许多医生来说，依赖核对清单的想法是有失身份的。作为医生或任何领域的专家，我们的价值观是我们相信自主性。别管我，我受过训练，我知道该怎么做，这就是你从我这里获得最好结果的最大保障。
bet for getting the best results out of whatever you're turning to me for. 700 miles away at Johns Hopkins Medicine in Baltimore, physician Peter Pronevost was struggling with the same problem. Peter had a perspective on patient safety that many doctors don't. He was in his fourth year of medical school when his father was misdiagnosed with a wrong cancer. Lymphoma instead of leukemia. And by the time they got it right, he came home with hospice and not only did he die, but he suffered miserably in pain for a week being told, oh, he has enough pain medicines. And at that time, I became convinced that health care often lets our patients down
700 英里之外，在巴尔的摩的约翰·霍普金斯医学院，内科医生彼得·普罗内沃斯特正在与同样的问题作斗争。彼得对患者安全有着许多医生所没有的视角。当他的父亲被误诊为错误类型的癌症时，他正读医学院四年级。是淋巴瘤而不是白血病。等他们确诊时，他带着临终关怀回家了，不仅死了，而且在痛苦中痛苦地折磨了一个星期，得到的回答是，哦，他的止痛药够了。就在那时，我确信医疗保健常常让我们的患者失望
and they deserve more. Peter was determined to do better by his patience. Figuring out exactly what that means and practice became a major goal of his work at Johns Hopkins. The work really accelerated back in 2001 after an adorable little girl, Josie King, died of a catheter infection. And those infections, to give you a perspective killed more people than breast or prostate cancer a year. It was a very big problem. A year after Josie's death, her mother, Ospeter, a very difficult question. Her mom, Cyrille, came to me and said, could you tell me that my daughter is less likely to die now than a year ago. And I looked at her
他们值得更好的对待。彼得决心为他的病人做得更好。弄清楚在实践中这意味着什么，成了他在约翰霍普金斯大学工作的主要目标。这项工作在2001年真正加速了，当时一个可爱的迷人小女孩乔西·金死于导管感染。为了让你有个概念，这些感染每年杀死的人比乳腺癌或前列腺癌还要多。这是一个非常大的问题。在乔西死后的一年里，她的母亲向彼得提出了一个非常困难的问题。她的妈妈西里尔来找我，说，你能告诉我，我女儿现在比一年前死亡的几率更低吗？我看着她
and reflected and said, I can't. A catheter is a thin tube that's inserted into the bladder to remove urine. Other times, catheters are put into the veins around the neck when a patient needs medicine or a blood transfusion. Hospitals around the world use catheters all the time. And those same hospitals routinely have problems when bacteria get into the tubing. Sometimes the infections caused by those bacteria can be so serious they lead to death, as in the case of Josie King. At the time we just accepted those infections as the norm.
反思并说，我不能。导管是一根插入膀胱以排出尿液的细管。有时，当患者需要药物或输血时，导管会被插入颈部周围的静脉中。世界各地的医院一直在使用导管。而这些医院也经常在细菌进入管道时遇到问题。有时由这些细菌引起的感染会非常严重，以至于导致死亡，就像乔西·金的情况一样。当时我们只是将这些感染视为常态。
That is the story that we told about health care was that sometimes when you treat old or young or very sick patients, little girls like Josie are going to die. There was a straightforward solution. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention had rolled out a checklist to prevent catheter-born infections. It included things like wash your hands with soap before inserting the catheter, cover the patients with sterile drapes, make sure that doctors and nurses wear gloves, hats, masks, and gowns. The checklist seems so obvious, so easy to follow, but Peter quickly found that
这就是我们对医疗保健的说法，有时当你治疗老年人、年轻人或重病患者时，像乔西这样的小女孩就会死去。有一个直接的解决方案。疾病控制与预防中心推出了一份用于预防导管感染的核对清单。它包括诸如在插入导管前用肥皂洗手、用无菌单覆盖患者、确保医生和护士佩戴手套、帽子、口罩和手术衣等内容。核对清单看起来如此显而易见，如此容易遵循，但彼得很快发现
creating a checklist is only the first step. There are lots of reasons for doctors and nurses to ignore it. To get all the equipment needed with the checklist, a cap, a gown, a mask, doctors had to go to eight different places, a capsule and one-placed masks or another, and when the equipment wasn't stocked and it often wasn't, the doctors made in their mind what was a rational economic decision. They said, if I go spend 10 minutes to run down the hall or to another unit to get this piece of equipment, that's 10 minutes I'm going to spend not caring for another patient or doing something else because there was no slack time. And if I go without it, the infection is invisible.
创建核对清单只是第一步。医生和护士有很多理由忽视它。为了拿齐核对清单所需的所有设备，帽子、手术衣、口罩，医生必须去八个不同的地方，帽子在一个地方，口罩在另一个地方，当设备没有备货时（这种情况经常发生），医生在心中做出了一个理性的经济决定。他们说，如果我花10分钟跑下走廊或去另一个单位拿这件设备，那将是我不去照顾另一个病人或做别的事情的10分钟，因为没有空闲时间。如果我不拿就去，感染是看不见的。
It's in the future. And it may not really be prevented anyways, so they often decided to go without it. So what we did was said, okay, let's make a cart, let's get all the equipment we need, store in one place, make sure someone's assigned to stock it, and now compliance with the checklist went from 30 to 75%. But even when all the supplies were closed at hand, there was a deeper problem that had to do with a culture of medicine. The power dynamic between doctors and nurses. Peter told nurses that they had the authority to stop physicians when they tried to put in catheters without following the checklist. It caused an uproar.
它在未来。而且无论如何可能都无法真正预防，所以他们经常决定不拿。所以我们所做的就是说，好吧，让我们做一个推车，把我们需要的所有设备拿来，存放在一个地方，确保有人负责备货，现在对核对清单的依从率从 30% 上升到了 75%。但即使所有物资都在手边，还有一个更深层次的问题，那就是医学文化。医生和护士之间的权力动态。彼得告诉护士，当医生试图在不遵循核对清单的情况下置入导管时，她们有权制止医生。这引起了一场骚乱。
The doctor said, you can't have a nurse questioning me in public. It makes me look like I don't know something. To which I said, welcome to the human me look like I don't know something to which I said welcome to the human race We all don't know things and the nurses said I'm not gonna question a doctor because if I do I'll get my head bit off. I'm tired of being yelled at. It's too risky and so I pulled the team together and said Do you all agree that harm should be prevented in this hospital? Yes, of course Peter We should never harm patients and do you agree that the items on the checklist are scientifically sound that patients should get them all the time? Yes, we agree with this, Peter. I said, then, okay, let me be clear. Doctors, you have permission to forget to use an item on
医生说，你不能让护士在公共场合质问我。这让我看起来像是不懂什么。对此我说，欢迎来到人类这让我看起来像是不懂什么，对此我说，欢迎来到人类。我们都有不懂的事，护士说，我不会质问医生，因为如果我这样做了，我会被骂得狗血淋头。我厌倦了被大吼大叫。这太冒险了，所以我把团队聚在一起说，你们都同意在这个医院里应该防止伤害吗？是的，当然，彼得，我们绝不应该伤害患者，你们同意核对清单上的项目在科学上是合理的，患者应该一直使用它们吗？是的，我们同意这一点，彼得。我说，那好吧，让我明确一点。医生，你们被允许忘记使用核对清单上的某项。
the checklist. We're human. We're going to, but you don't have permission to needlessly put patients at risk. So if you forget, nurse or patient or anybody else will question you and you will go back to fix it. Not because of power, but because it's the right thing to do for patients. And nurses, please page me any time of day or night if you get your head bit off. Peter wasn't paged. and the number of patients developing infections started to drop. Compliance went from 75% with the checklist to around 98% infection rates went from 5,000 catheter days to 2% and so we knew we were on to something and so we started investigating every infection as a defect,
我们是人。我们会忘的，但你们没有资格让患者承担不必要的风险。所以如果你忘记了，护士或患者或其他任何人都会质问你，而你将回去纠正它。不是因为权力，而是因为这对患者来说是正确的事。护士们，如果你们被骂得狗血淋头，请在白天或晚上的任何时间呼叫我。彼得没有被呼叫。发生感染的患者数量开始下降。核对清单的依从率从 75% 左右上升到 98%，感染率从 5,000 个导管日下降到 2%，所以我们知道我们走对了路，于是我们开始将每一次感染都作为缺陷进行调查，
to get changing the narrative that no longer are these inevitable, but they're preventable. And what did we find? Well, we found now that the remaining infections were often in people who had catheters for a long time. And it had nothing to do with how we inserted them. The checklist I had originally made, but how we maintained them, how the nurses accessed them.
改变这种叙事，不再认为这些是不可避免的，而是可预防的。我们发现了什么？好吧，我们现在发现其余的感染通常发生在长期使用导管的人身上。这与我们如何插入它们无关。我最初制作的核对清单，而是关于我们如何维护它们，护士如何使用它们。
So we made a checklist for that and made sure that they accessed the catheters the right way and infection rates went to zero. Indeed, we went over a year without having any of these infections. And it was just a remarkable new narrative that with a disciplined focus and cohesive effort, harm could be eliminated. Peter became an evangelist for checklists, but he was often asked whether the results he got at Hopkins, one of the nation's top medical centers, could be replicated in smaller cash strapped hospitals. He got his chance to study the question in 2004 when the state of Michigan decided to try
因此，我们为此制作了一份核对清单，并确保他们以正确的方式使用导管，感染率降到了零。事实上，我们有一年多的时间没有发生任何此类感染。这是一个了不起的新叙事，即通过专注的注意力和内聚的努力，伤害是可以被消除的。彼得成了核对清单的传道者，但他经常被问到他在霍普金斯（全国顶尖医疗中心之一）取得的成果，是否可以在资金短缺的小型医院中复制。他在2004年获得了研究这个问题的机会，当时密歇根州决定尝试
using the catheter checklist in more than 100 of its hospitals. The results, which were published in the New England Journal of Medicine, showed a dramatic drop in catheter-related infection rates in that state all the way to zero. Those results were maintained throughout the 18 months of the study and in a follow-up study with 90 of the hospitals that was published in 2010. Peter has since left Johns Hopkins. In the year since his research there, many hospital systems have tried out versions of his checklist.
在100多家医院中使用导管核对清单。这些结果发表在《新英格兰医学杂志》上，显示该州的导管相关感染率急剧下降，一直降至零。这些结果在整个为期 18 个月的试验中得以保持，并在 2010 年发表的对 90 家医院的后续研究中也得到了维持。彼得后来离开了约翰霍普金斯大学。在他离开那里的研究之后的几年里，许多医院系统都尝试了他的核对清单的版本。
Some of those efforts have been successful. Others? Not so much. Why? Checklists are really only as good as the teams that implement them. Peter says, teams that work in a top-down, bureaucratic fashion are simply less likely to benefit from checklists. Too often, we tell people how to do things.
其中一些努力成功了。其他的呢？没那么成功。为什么？核对清单的好坏取决于实施它们的团队。彼得说，以自上而下的官僚方式工作的团队更不容易从核对清单中受益。通常情况下，我们告诉人们如何做事。
That is the checklist without explaining why and what's important. I'll never forget, I was working with a nurse manager, putting one of our projects our projects in and the ICU attending who were passionate about this stuff. They got religion. They picked up the Hopkins checklist and said Peter this is great. We will go tell our staff that they will use your checklist. There's no question. We will force them to use it and I said you won't work. Do not do that. Have a conversation them about why this is important. Ask them if little girls like Josie are dying in their hospital and if that's acceptable. Discuss that the goal of zero infection is. And then say, let's figure out how to make
这就是核对清单，却没有解释为什么以及什么才是重要的。我永远不会忘记，我曾与一位护士经理一起工作，将我们的项目项目和对这事充满热情的 ICU 主治医生推进。他们皈依了。他们拿起了霍普金斯的核对清单并说，彼得，这太棒了。我们会告诉我们的员工，他们将使用你的核对清单。毫无疑问。我们会强迫他们使用它，我说，这行不通。不要那样做。与他们对话，谈谈为什么这很重要。问问他们像乔西这样的小女孩是否在他们的医院死去，这是否可以接受。讨论零感染的目标是什么。然后说，让我们弄清楚如何制作
sure patients always get this best practice. So, engaging people to co-create the solutions and respecting their wisdom in autonomy is really important in how we do this. Engaging people in this deep way, talking with them about shared goals, working together to translate those goals into a to-do list that they could use every day, all this takes a lot of work. Skeptics have asked Peter whether his system works only and relatively straightforward settings. You really can't follow five simple rules when inserting a catheter.
确保患者始终能享受到这种最佳实践。因此，让人们共同参与制定解决方案，在具体做法中尊重他们的智慧与自主性非常重要。以这种深入的方式让人们参与进来，与他们讨论共同的目标，合作将这些目标转化为他们每天都可以使用的待办事项清单，所有这一切都需要付出大量的努力。怀疑论者曾问彼得，他的系统是否只适用于相对简单的环境。在插入导尿管时，你总不能遵循五条简单的规则吧。
But what about when you're doing surgery? There is no recipe for doing an operation. There are a million ways things can go wrong. When we come back, we're going to go into the operating room. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. Surjin Atul Gawande has quite literally written the book on the power of checklist to help us grapple with complicated tasks. But there was a time not long ago when Artur would routinely perform a complex surgery without a checklist. Sometimes, he wouldn't even know all the people he was working alongside in the operating room.
但是当你做手术时情况又如何呢？做手术可没有现成的秘诀。事情出错的方式有一百万种。当我们回来时，我们将进入手术室。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。外科医生阿图尔·加万迪（Atul Gawande）可以说是写了一本关于核对清单威力的书，来帮助我们应对复杂的任务。但就在不久前，阿图尔还经常在没有核对清单的情况下常规进行复杂的手术。有时，他甚至都不知道在手术室里与他并肩工作的有哪些人。
I would just walk in. It was kind of expected to be a silent place where people didn't ask a lot of questions. They're just supposed to know what they're doing. And then you just proceed. And then when something goes wrong, you'd be like, you know, why didn't you guys know what the hell you were doing? And either, you know, that kind of ridiculous lack of preparation was the typical story. Atul, like Johns Hopkins Physician Peter Pronevost, became interested early in his career in the routines and assumptions embedded in medicine. How much was the success of a surgeon about talent and training? How much of it was about having strong procedures
我就会直接走进去。这里原本被认为是一个应该保持安静的地方，人们不会问太多问题。他们本该知道自己在做什么。然后你只需继续进行。接着当事情出错时，你就会想，你知道的，你们怎么会不知道自己到底在干什么？无论如何，那种荒谬的缺乏准备是典型的故事。阿图尔和约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的医生彼得·普罗诺沃斯特一样，在他的职业生涯早期就开始对医学中蕴含的常规和假设产生兴趣。外科医生的成功有多少取决于天赋和培训？又有多少取决于拥有强大的规程
and teamwork? Otto began to look for answers to those questions. I'd done a study with several other researchers while I was in my training, where I got to look at data from a team that had gathered information from hospitals across Utah and Colorado. And they were looking at people who had a major complication
和团队合作？阿图尔开始寻找这些问题的答案。我在接受培训期间曾与几位其他研究人员做过一项研究，当时我得以查看一个团队的数据，该团队收集了来自犹他州和科罗拉多州各地医院的信息。他们当时正在调查遭受重大并发症
or a death during a hospital admission. And I found two things in examining the data. Two thirds of the patients who'd had a major major disability or death as a bad outcome from their care were surgical patients. And furthermore, I found at least two-thirds of those patients turned out to have died from a problem where we had the answer but didn't execute on it. In fact, it was a very tiny percentage of patients who had a major disability or death that was due to a problem that we hadn't discovered the answer for. It was mostly
或在住院期间死亡的患者。我在检查数据时发现了两件事。在因治疗结果不佳而遭受重大残疾或死亡的患者中，有三分之二都是外科患者。此外，我发现其中至少三分之二的患者最终死于一个我们其实知道答案但却没有执行好的问题。事实上，遭遇重大残疾或死亡的患者中，只有极小一部分是因为我们尚未找到答案的问题所导致的。这主要
a problem of lack of execution. People were suffering and in some cases dying because surgical teams were making preventable errors overlooking basic steps that could make an operation safer. Otto realized that the unsexy task of developing better surgical procedures was actually the most important work he could do. The volume of surgery had exploded around the world as people lived longer to more than 300 million operations worldwide, one for every 2022 or so human beings. But the death rates
是一个缺乏执行力的问题。人们遭受痛苦，在某些情况下甚至死亡，是因为外科团队犯了可避免的错误，忽略了本可以让手术更安全的的基本步骤。阿图尔意识到，开发更好的外科手术程序这项看似平淡无奇的任务，其实是他能做的最重要工作。随着人们寿命延长，全球的手术量激增，全世界每年进行超过3.03亿次手术，平均每2022人左右就有一例。但死亡率
were 10 to 100 times higher than in childbirth. So that meant that we needed to look at this as a public health problem. Otto started looking more deeply at the problem. He was intrigued by the study Peter Pronevost had conducted in Michigan. Peter had found that using a checklist could dramatically reduce catheter infections. Otto decided to develop a checklist for surgical teams. We worked with a variety of teams, experts in anesthesia, infectious disease, surgery, nursing, and so on. He also went to Seattle to meet with airline safety experts at Boeing. And one of the key points that the Boeing folks emphasize to us is that it has to
却比分娩时高出10到100倍。所以这意味着我们需要将此视为一个公共卫生问题。阿图尔开始更深入地研究这个问题。他对彼得·普罗诺沃斯特在密歇根州开展的研究很感兴趣。彼得发现，使用核对清单可以显著减少导尿管感染。阿图尔决定为外科团队开发一个核对清单。我们与各种团队进行了合作，包括麻醉、传染病、外科、护理等领域的专家。他还前往西雅图，与波音公司的航空安全专家会面。波音公司的人向我们强调的关键点之一是，它必须
fit into the workflow and cannot be a distraction from the core things you're doing and make matters worse. So if you're launching an rocket into space, you have all the time in the world. You, you get one shot at this thing, right? Whereas we do 50 million operations per year in the United States. We have a lot of people we have to take care of. And if we, you know, if we only get through half of them, we have a whole lot of people who end up being harmed
融入工作流程中，而不能分散你对核心工作的注意力，从而让事情变得更糟。因此，如果你要将一枚火箭发射到太空中，你有的是时间。你，你只有一次机会，对吧？而我们在美国每年进行5000万次手术。我们有很多需要照顾的人。如果我们，你知道的，如果我们只能完成其中一半，我们就会有一大堆人在这个过程中
along the way. So we set some terms around this. You, we have, we have two minutes total for a check before the patients put to sleep, a check before the incisions made and a check before the person leaves the room. And then can we run through it in such a way that you're identifying the killer items, you want to chunk it because the brain can only handle five to nine items at a time. So we had to chunk it into components that allow people to run through it in a reasonable way,
受到伤害。因此，我们围绕这一点设定了一些条款。你，我们有，我们在患者麻醉前总共有两分钟的核对时间，在切开切口前进行核对，以及在患者离开房间前进行核对。然后我们能否以这样一种方式进行核对：你能识别出那些关键致命的项目，你需要把它分成小块，因为大脑一次只能处理五到九个项目。所以我们不得不把它分成几个部分，让人们能够以合理的方式进行核对，
while having a potentially emergency patient on the table in front of you. Once he had a basic checklist in hand, it was time to test it out. Surgical teams in eight cities around the world agreed to give it a try. We're all tensed,, a city hospital in Delhi to some of the wealthiest places. University of Washington Medical Center in Seattle, St. Mary's Hospital in London, Toronto
同时你面前的手术台上可能还躺着一个处于紧急状况的患者。一旦他手头有了基础核对清单，就是时候对其进行测试了。全球八个城市的外科团队同意尝试一下。我们都在紧张地关注着，从德里的一家城市医院到一些最富裕的地方。西雅图的华盛顿大学医学中心、伦敦圣玛丽医院、多伦多
General Hospital, and in every hospital you had a reduction in complications, the average reduction in complications was 35%, the reduction of deaths was 47%. A 47% reduction in deaths, checklists that seemed could be as powerful in a surgical setting as they were in reducing catheter infections. Since Attu published those findings, checklists have become a standard part of surgeries in hospitals around the world including at the hospital where atul works
总医院，在每一家医院，并发症都有所减少，并发症平均减少了35%，死亡人数减少了47%。死亡人数减少47%，事实证明，核对清单在外科手术环境中可能与减少导尿管感染一样威力巨大。自从阿图尔发表这些发现以来，核对清单已经成为全球各地医院手术的标准部分，包括阿图尔工作的医院在内。
Operating rooms at Brigham & Women's Hospital in Boston are crowded and busy places You have lots of surgical equipment and monitors and lots of people in motion Atul Gawande and a group of colleagues are preparing to perform a surgery. Their patient is a woman named Heather Parsons. They're reviewing Heather's medical history and the plan for her surgery. One member of the team asks Heather to confirm the procedure they're about to perform.
波士顿布莱根妇女医院的手术室里拥挤而忙碌。这里有大量的手术设备和监视器，还有许多走动的人。阿图尔·加万迪和一群同事正准备实施一台手术。他们的患者是一位名叫海瑟·帕森斯（Heather Parsons）的女士。他们正在回顾海瑟的病史以及手术计划。团队的一名成员请海瑟确认他们即将进行的手术。
Are DNA partial thyroid or chinidobarides? Okay, so the right side of the side that has been marked right there and the cracked side that we're working on were on the agreement? Yes, okay, so I'll take over the side that has been marked right there and the cracked side that we're working on, we're on an agreement? Yes, okay, so I'll take over from here. Heather and the team agree that they're going to do a partial thyroidectomy on the right side of her body. It can be a little hard to hear everything here.
是部分甲状腺切除术还是下巴手术？好的，所以被标记的那一侧就是右侧，我们正在操作的正确一侧，我们达成了一致？是的，好的，那我就从这里接手。海瑟和团队一致同意，他们将在她身体的右侧进行部分甲状腺切除术。这里的一切听起来可能有点困难。
Microphones are not very easy to sterilize, and since infection control is a major concern, we had to record some distance from the action. The team goes over concerns they had in the lead up to the surgery and they tell Heather how they plan to address those concerns. Then they begin anesthesia. After Heather goes to sleep, the team formally begins their surgical safety checklist. They again review her full name, date of birth, allergies, and the plan for the surgery. And then they do something that might not occur to those of us who've never watched a surgery.
麦克风不是很容易消毒，而且由于感染控制是一个重大问题，我们不得不记录距离手术现场一定距离的声音。团队回顾了他们在手术前遇到的担忧，并告诉海瑟他们计划如何解决这些担忧。然后他们开始实施麻醉。海瑟入睡后，团队正式开始进行外科手术安全核对清单。他们再次核对她的全名、出生日期、过敏史以及手术计划。然后他们做了一件对于从未观看过手术的我们来说可能不会想到的事情。
They do introductions. They confirm that they have all the equipment they need and they doublecheck that there are no other medical concerns that need to be addressed. Then, with George Michael's song Faith in the background, they begin the surgery. It might seem obvious that surgical teams should run through a routine like this. Of course, each person should know the name of everyone else on the team. Of course, everyone needs to be on the same page about the surgery they're performing and the potential risks. But until checklist became a rule, these obvious things weren't always put into practice.
他们进行了自我介绍。他们确认自己拥有所需的所有设备，并仔细检查没有其他需要解决的医疗问题。然后，在乔治·迈克尔（George Michael）的歌曲《Faith》的背景音乐中，他们开始了手术。外科团队应该经历这样一套常规程序，这似乎是显而易见的。当然，每个人都应该知道团队中其他所有人的名字。当然，每个人都需要对他们所进行的手术以及潜在风险达成共识。但在核对清单成为一项规则之前，这些显而易见的事情并不总是付诸实践。
Atul says it's worth remembering that checklists have not been universally successful. They only work if medical teams tailor them to their own needs and their own local cultures. When we ask people for their copies of the checklist, looking at 100 checklists, virtually every one of them has been changed and customized in some way that they've done locally. And I've seen checklists that take our 19 items and made them more than 80 items.
阿图尔说，值得记住的是，核对清单并没有获得普遍成功。只有当医疗团队根据自身需求和当地文化对其进行定制时，它们才起作用。当我们向人们索取他们的核对清单副本时，通过查看100份核对清单，几乎每一份清单都在某种程度上被当地人进行了修改和定制。我见过将我们原本的19个项目扩充到80多个项目的核对清单。
An administration had taken over the control of the checklists. They piled all these things on, and then everybody ignored that, started ignoring them, because you just couldn't make it work in a day where you had to get through taking care of the patients. One big cautionary tale, he says,
行政管理部门接管了对核对清单的控制。他们把所有这些东西都堆上去，然后每个人都置之不理，开始无视它们，因为你根本无法在必须照顾患者的一天里让它发挥作用。他说，一个重大的前车之鉴，
is how the surgical checklist was rolled out in Canada. So in Canada and Ottawa, they deployed it by making it a law. You have to do this in the hospital and the hospitals then would sign off that they followed the law. And they got a 0% improvement in death because there wasn't an actual implementation program. Contrast this to what happened in South Carolina. The State's Hospital Association reached out to Atul to ask him for his help in launching a surgical checklist initiative. Atul says South Carolina's program, unlike Canada's, was voluntary.
就是外科核对清单在加拿大是如何推行的。所以在加拿大的渥太华，他们通过立法的方式来部署它。你必须在医院里这么做，然后医院会签署确认他们遵守了法律。但他们的死亡率改善为0%，因为根本没有实际的实施计划。这与南卡罗来纳州发生的情况形成了鲜明对比。该州的医院协会主动联系阿图尔，请求他协助发起一项外科手术核对清单倡议。阿图尔说，南卡罗来纳州的项目与加拿大的不同，它是自愿的。
There was a lengthy process to make sure teams at each hospital understood the point of the checklist. They were encouraged to change it, make it their own. There was also a game plan to deal with hospital politics. Expect you're going to have some surgeons who say this isn't such a great idea. I don't want to do it. And we had a strategy for approaching those folks, which is simply to go in and see them one-on-one and just ask, will you help? And more often than not, people will. In the end, about 25% of South Carolina's hospitals, which take care of 40% of the state's population, took part in the checklist effort.
这是一个漫长的过程，旨在确保每家医院的团队都理解核对清单的意义。他们被鼓励去修改它，使其成为他们自己的东西。还有一个应对医院政治的总体规划。要预料到会有一些外科医生说这不是个好主意。我不想这么做。我们针对这些人制定了策略，那就是直接去拜访他们，进行一对一的交流，只需问一句：你愿意帮帮忙吗？通常情况下，人们都会愿意。最终，南卡罗来纳州大约25%的医院参与了核对清单推广工作，这些医院承担了该州40%人口的医疗服务。
Atul says those hospitals saw 22% reduction in patient deaths. And that was as many lives saved as would have died in car accidents in that population. These results, the first large scale study of surgical checklist use in a general patient population were recently published in the journal Anals of Medicine. Atul has spent a lot of time thinking about checklists. Yes, they can reduce deaths and they can reduce hospital infections. But they can also do something else that's surprising. They can generate a feeling of teamwork and shared purpose.
阿图尔说，这些医院的患者死亡率下降了22%。这挽救的生命数量，相当于该群体中死于车祸的人数。这些结果——作为对普通患者群体中外科手术核对清单使用情况的首个大规模研究——最近发表在《内科学年鉴》（Annals of Medicine）杂志上。阿图尔花了很多时间思考核对清单。是的，它们可以减少死亡人数，还可以减少医院感染。但它们还可以做另一件令人惊讶的事情。它们能够产生一种团队合作精神和共同的目标感。
Operating rooms are often people who are getting together at the start of a day as a completely new team. You will have people coming together in combinations that sometimes have never really worked together before or haven't worked together in a long time. You know, the nurse on duty for the day, the anesthesiologist on duty for the day, a resident participating. And so you have to quickly make that team gel in coalesce. The act of people speaking up and just hearing themselves say their name in the room,
手术室里的人通常是在一天的开始时作为一个全新的团队聚在一起。你会发现，人们以有时从未真正合作过、或者很久没有合作过的组合形式聚集在一起。你知道的，当班的护士、当班的麻醉师、参与其中的住院医师。所以你必须迅速让这个团队凝聚融合。人们大声说话、只是听到自己在房间里说出自己名字的行为，
studies have shown that when people have had that chance to introduce themselves, they're much more likely to speak up later. And that's what we're now recognizing is that the, that when you just stand and watch a team that has used the checklist, there is much more likelihood that people will raise questions, feel comfortable saying, hmm, I don't quite understand why XYZ is happening. And in general, you see much more equality of voices in the room. You have as much talking to be likely from a nurse, a surgeon, and an anesthesiologist rather than
研究表明，当人们有机会进行自我介绍后，他们在之后更有可能大声说出来。而我们现在认识到的是，当你站在一旁观察一个使用过核对清单的团队时，人们提出问题、感觉可以舒适地说出“嗯，我不太明白为什么会发生某某情况”的可能性要大得多。总的来说，你会发现房间里各种声音的平等性大大增强。护士、外科医生和麻醉师发声的可能性差不多，而不是
one or another dominating. Is it, is the idea of the checklist you can basically do away with the expert now? In other words, if you can come up with a list of things to do, can I be the surgeon that you are, or the pilot that flies Boeing planes? Yeah, no, absolutely not. Oh, done, right? So one of the amazing things that just looking at these checklists is they're made for experts use.
某一个人占主导地位。那么，核对清单的理念是不是意味着你现在基本上可以取代专家了？换句话说，如果你能列出一份要做的事情清单，我能成为像你这样的外科医生，或者驾驶波音飞机的飞行员吗？是的，不，绝对不能。哦，完成了，对吧？所以，看看这些核对清单，最神奇的事情之一就是它们是为专家使用而制作的。
They're not an algorithm. They're not a recipe for flying a plane. They are the, you know, here in this moment of the five most common ways that things go wrong. It's put into a very professional, terse language. You know, it's almost like one word or two words. Check. Have you got this? Have you got that? Check. And then you move on. It's aimed to be a supplement to your brain. Both activating it and advancing it.
它们不是算法。它们不是飞行飞机的秘诀。它们是，你知道的，此时此地最常见的五种出错方式。它们被写成非常专业、简练的语言。你知道的，几乎就是一个词或两个词。核对。你做这个了吗？你做那个了吗？核对。然后你继续。它的目的是作为你大脑的补充。既能激活大脑又能提升大脑。
And that's, to me, some of the coolest aspects of it, because this is what enables a professional to function at this incredible level of performance. There are a million ways that things can go wrong, but there is a recipe for being ready for how to handle it. Is everybody understand why you're here, what the what the background medical issues are of this person? Do we all understand what each other's roles are, do we know how long the case will take? Are we ready for the unexpected? And by doing that, that's putting you in an entirely different place. It's a place that he says doesn't have to be reserved only for doctors or pilots or
在我看来，这正是其中最酷的一些方面，因为这使得专业人员能够以这种令人难以置信的水平发挥性能。事情出错的方式有一百万种，但却有一个秘诀来准备好如何应对它。每个人都明白你为什么在这里吗，这个人的背景医疗问题是什么？我们都理解彼此的角色吗，我们知道这个病例需要多长时间吗？我们为意料之外的情况做好准备了吗？通过这样做，这就把你带到了一种完全不同的境地。他说，这是一个不必只留给医生、飞行员或
people in high stress jobs. At all things, we could all benefit from checklist. The reason checklists are fascinating to me is that they're the oldest, most simple system human beings have invented for dealing with the limitations of our brain and also limitations of working together as a team. I got to talk about this on the Cal Bear report. Americans don't need checklists, we f**k it. Okay?
从事高压力工作的人的境地。阿图尔认为，我们所有人都可以从核对清单中受益。核对清单之所以让我着迷，是因为它们是人类为了应对我们大脑的局限性以及团队合作的局限性而发明的最古老、最简单的系统。我在《科尔伯特报告》（Colbert Report）上谈论过这个。美国人不需要核对清单，我们直接开干。好吗？
All right? Check one. Show up to work. Two, be American. Okay. And greatest workers in the world. That's so cool, I get to go on. Do you use checklists? So we... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... the world. That's so cool, I get to go on. Do you use checklist?
好吧？第一项。去上班。第二项，当个美国人。好吧。世界上最伟大的工人。太酷了，我能继续了。你用核对清单吗？所以我们……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……世界。太棒了，我能继续说下去了。你用核对清单吗？
So we do use a checklist. I finally began using a checklist in the last couple of years. What do you do with a checklist? Well, it turned out one of the, the main reason you wanted me on was then to talk about, you said, hey, is there a checklist for what we do? Because this drives me crazy. Every day, we have planned out the whole show,
所以我们确实在使用核对清单。我最近几年终于开始使用核对清单了。你用核对清单做什么？嗯，事实证明，你让我上节目的主要原因之一就是来谈谈这个，你说：“嘿，我们做的事情有没有核对清单？”因为这让我抓狂。每天我们都把整个节目计划好了，
then around three o'clock, there'll be some breaking news thing, and you have to completely remake the jokes. And it always ends up falling apart, and there are mistakes left and right because we're remaking the show half the time on the fly. How would we have a checklist for breaking news comedy? And it's totally doable. You can look at what happens every time, what are the things that go wrong, and how can you have a series of checks so you're not making the same mistakes over and over and over again. Surgeon's pilots and parents often have to raise to get things done.
然后在大约三点钟，会有一些突发新闻出现，你必须彻底重新创作笑话。结果总是弄得一团糟，到处都是错误，因为我们有一半时间都在现场临时重新制作节目。我们怎么能为突发新闻喜剧准备一份核对清单呢？这完全是可行的。你可以看看每次发生了什么，出问题的是什么，以及如何通过一系列检查，让你不会一遍又一遍地犯同样的错误。外科医生、飞行员和父母经常不得不匆忙行事来把事情做好。
The more we rush, the easier it becomes to trip over something and take a fall. Checklists won't necessarily solve all problems of modern living. Airplanes and space shuttles will still crash, despite elaborate checklists. Surgeries will still go wrong, even when a team takes the time to anticipate the risks. Merely setting up checklists won't mean that we follow them. We can set up a calendar alert, reminding us of a 5pm project deadline, and then procrastinate all the way until 445 before we try to get it done. Checklists can also be so long and complicated that they become self-defeating.
我们越是匆忙，就越容易被什么东西绊倒并摔倒。核对清单不一定能解决现代生活中的所有问题。尽管有精心制作的核对清单，飞机和航天飞机仍然会坠毁。即使团队花时间去预见风险，手术仍然会出错。仅仅建立核对清单并不意味着我们会遵循它们。我们可以设置日历提醒，提醒我们下午5点有一个项目截止日期，然后一直拖延到4点45分才试图去完成它。核对清单也可能又长又复杂，以至于适得其反。
You can draw up a comprehensive list before heading to the supermarket and then come home and find you forgot to get the coffee. But what checklists do accomplish is they get us to focus on things that are most likely to trip us up. Over time, preventing the most common errors will have the biggest impact on our lives.
你可以在去超市前拟定一份详尽的清单，结果回家后发现自己忘了买咖啡。但核对清单真正做到的是，它们让我们专注于最容易绊倒我们的事情。随着时间的推移，预防最常见的错误将对我们的生活产生最大的影响。
Perhaps most important, checklists are one of humanity's oldest tools to combat our blind spots and our arrogance. The humble checklist reminds us of the importance of humility because in the end we're only human. Since this episode came out last fall, Atul and his team published a large study on checklists in rural India. They wanted to see if checklists could prevent deaths of mothers and newborns.
也许最重要的是，核对清单是人类对抗盲区和傲慢的最古老工具之一。简陋的核对清单提醒我们谦逊的重要性，因为说到底我们都只是凡人。自从去年秋天这一集播出以来，阿图尔和他的团队发表了一项关于印度农村核对清单的大型研究。他们想看看核对清单是否能防止母亲和新生儿死亡。
They found that checklists didn't change mortality rates, in part because they weren't enough highly skilled health care providers and because of inadequate access to basic medical supplies such as running water and clean towels. Atold says this finding reinforces the idea that checklist aren't a panacea for all problems in a complicated healthcare system. This week's episode was produced by Tara Boyle. A team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parts Cha, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle, and Aditi Bandlamudi. We had original music composed by Rampti and Arableui. Our Ransang heroes this week are Atul Gawande's colleagues Debra O'Neil, Tania Palethusain,
他们发现核对清单并没有改变死亡率，部分原因在于缺乏高技能的医护人员，以及缺乏自来水和干净毛巾等基本医疗物资。阿图尔说，这一发现强化了这样一个观点：核对清单并不是解决复杂医疗系统中所有问题的万灵药。本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）制作。团队成员包括詹妮弗·施密特（Jennifer Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕茨·查（Parts Cha）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）和阿迪蒂·班德拉穆迪（Aditi Bandlamudi）。我们的原创音乐由兰普蒂（Rampti）和阿拉布鲁伊（Arableui）作曲。我们本周的幕后英雄是阿图尔·加万迪的同事黛布拉·奥尼尔（Debra O'Neil）、塔尼亚·帕莱图森（Tania Palethusain）、
Laurie Shrath, Angel Laiala, and Samuel Kim. Figuring out how to get audio from Atul and his colleagues in surgery was not easy. There were all kinds of hurdles around infection control and patient privacy. Deborah, Tanya and Laurie spent many hours working to overcome those hurdles. They also managed to carve out time in a busy surgeon's schedule for not one, but two interviews. Angel and Sam got the sound you heard from the operating room at Brigham & Women's Hospital. Many thanks to all of you. You can find more of our reporting on Facebook and Twitter.
劳里·施拉特（Laurie Shrath）、安杰尔·拉亚拉（Angel Laiala）和萨姆·金（Samuel Kim）。弄清楚如何从手术室里的阿图尔及其同事那里获取音频可不容易。在感染控制和患者隐私方面存在各种各样的障碍。黛布拉、塔尼亚和劳里花了许多个小时来努力克服这些障碍。他们还在忙碌的外科医生日程中设法挤出时间，进行了不仅一次，而是两次采访。安杰尔和萨姆录下了你在布莱根妇女医院手术室里听到的声音。非常感谢你们所有人。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们的更多报道。
If you like this episode of the show, one request. Please make your own checklist of all the friends you think might enjoy hidden brain and share the show with them. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集的节目，我们有一个请求。请为你认为会喜欢《隐藏的大脑》的所有朋友制作一份你自己的核对清单，并与他们分享这个节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。下周见。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。